un homme Anthony Laroche propose à des
femmes qui la séduite en ligne de
coucher avec lui
comme dans le livre sans jamais le voir
les yeux bandés
parmi elles Sophie la trentaine
il s'est présenté comme un architecte
d'intérieur de 37 ans
ont passé des heures à discuter il m'a
appelé tous les jours
il me disait qu'il avait envie d'être
avec moi et mais oui c'était un homme un
très bel homme sur les photos
c'est lui qui a lancé le scénario de se
rencontrer chez lui je ne voulais pas et
en fait il m'a clairement lavé le
cerveau pendant plusieurs semaines et il
m'a toujours dit le jour où tu seras
prête on le fera
elle finit par accepter la proposition
du Bel Anthony Laroche
problème il n'existe pas
il s'agit en fait d'un homme de plus de
60 ans plus papy que Playboy
mais Sophie ne le voit pas dans cet
appartement plongé dans le noir
m'a dit déshabille-toi mais le bandeau
sur tes yeux et il est venu me chercher
il m'a emmené dans la chambre
et là il m'a attaché les mains au lit et
là j'ai commencé à
me demander à me demander si c'était
normal
et
moi il s'est passé ce qui s'est passé et
donc à la fin quand j'ai enlevé le
bandeau il était allongé à côté de moi
dans le lit et je réalise que j'ai été
violée parce que la personne qui était
assise à côté de moi dans le lit mais
c'était pas du tout la personne avec qui
je pensais être et cet homme là je lui
ai jamais donné mon mon accord parce que
c'est pas cette personne là que j'allais
voir et du coup bah
[Musique]
je me sentais sale j'ai été prendre une
douche je suis resté je crois une heure
sous la douche si j'avais pu m'arracher
la peau je crois que j'aurais fait enfin
j'étais vraiment pas bien ça a été très
très dur
Sophie porte plainte pour viol par
surprise tout comme deux autres femmes
mais pour le moment la justice considère
les charges insuffisantes pour renvoyer
l'affaire devant les assises motif
l'effet de viol ne sont pas caractérisés
les victimes étaient consentantes
pendant l'acte c'est en tout cas le
point de vue défendu par les avocats du
faux Anthony Laroche
oui on est vraiment dans le cas d'un
fantasme sexuel qui était consenti dès
le début de part et d'autre que ce soit
de la part de nos clients mais également
de la part des plaignantes
de contraintes de menaces de
séquestration genre de choses qu'on peut
imaginer pour des faits entre de viol
classique enfin dans la conception du
viol qu'on peut avoir
pour eux cette histoire se résume à une
simple affaire de duperie où les femmes
bernées ne seraient victimes que de leur
naïveté
on a quand même le un prototype quand
même d'un homme vous voyez sa mâchoire
ses yeux son regard ténébreux châtain
aux yeux bleus je pense que si on est
normalement diligent on peut se poser
aussi la question de se dire à quel
moment je peux prétendre avoir comme ta
maman un mannequin